[MUSIC]
I, as a normal academic,
abhor social media.
I refuse to get onto Facebook or Twitter.
But I was really intrigued,
kind of like I am for designing for
VRAR, this opportunity to
leverage social networks and
concepts like story to
create good in the world.
And my husband and I at the time were
playing with this idea of writing a book
called The Dragonfly Effect.
So as a baby step into that possibility,
I taught a class called
power of social technology.
And one of my students invited Robert
to come, I don't know who Robert is.
Robert seems just like
a guy who likes tech,
which was like most the people there.
He comes up to me and he says,
can I have your Twitter handle?
I'd like to Tweet that I'm in the class.
And I had to go,
yes absolutely, just one sec.
And then I called my husband,
I said, do I have a Twitter handle?
Because Robert wants it.
I think he quickly got me one and
said it's at @aaker.
So I come back to Robert and I say I do.
@aaker, of course.
And he tweets me and
it was this visceral feeling of adrenaline
surge as about five hundred people within
a space of two minutes start following me.
So that was my Robert Scoble story.
It's really an honor to have Robert here.
He just wrote a book called
The Fourth Transformation.
And we were noodling on what he could
do with this designing for VRAR class.
And he talked about Meron, about Eric,
about all of the people
that he was working with.
And he thought, wouldn't it be
interesting to have very tight talks,
just ten minute talks.
We're opening up this and
live streaming it.
And then he'll curate a conversation.
So it's less a panel and
more a focus on the future of AR and
VR and mixed reality more generally.
And then there'll be
an interactive piece of it.
So that's what we're
going to do today with that.
I'd like to introduce all of our guests to
the class and to give you some context.
These are 40 people who are in undergrad,
grad, and then the GSB,
who are all excited, thrilled about
mixed reality, more generally.
And then because we're trying to
create more content that's open,
we also invited the wait list for
the class, and so that's who's here.
And we're really honored to have you here,
and
hoping you can introduce
the guest as well.
Thank you.
>> I'm honored to be here.
>> [APPLAUSE]
And particularly at this point in time
because I believe in June, Apple is about
to announce more new technologies than
it has ever shipped in its history.
They're preparing a new iPad,
a new TV, a new watch,
three new iPhones and new glasses.
All mixed reality.
All that are going to be a lot smaller
than the Hololens which I'm holding.
The Hololens, if you haven't seen it,
has sensors on it.
Senses the room you're in and
puts virtual things on top of it.
It does full-on next generation augmented
reality or mixed reality that we call it.
>> And it's quite exciting, right?
When you have mixed reality, you can
have aliens coming through your walls.
And you can walk around these things
coming through the walls, and
shooting them with your fingers,
and it's quite crazy.
This is also going to bring us
a virtual reality inside here.
In fact,
I have a little video that shows that.
Yeah, let's talk about this.
[COUGH]
So at CES, I just came from CES and
Sundance, so I'm fairly up to
date on what's coming soon.
The thing on the right is a luminous lens
in that green glass that
has a 720P monitor on it.
And it's the same thickness
as the Snapchat spectacles.
And it's going to cost less than $500 and
it's less than four ounces.
And Apple is rumored to have
better lenses than this.
because this was created by a company
like at $60 million of investment.
And Carl Zeiss is the one
building the Apple Glass, so
they better have a wider field of view and
more resolution than this.
But Apple's rumored to take everything
out of the glass that is possible.
They're not going to put a computer
in there like this one has.
The computer's going to be in your phone.
And the glasses are going to
have a very small computer that
displays what's coming
off the GPU on the phone.
And sends the 3D sensor
reading down to the phone so
that it can compute and
generate this mixed reality world.
They're hardly alone.
I know nine companies at least that are
developing glasses like this or optics.
And you're going to see Hololens 2 soon,
like in the next 18 months.
You're going to see Apple come out.
You're going to see Facebook come out.
You're going to see Meta and ODG.
Google, Google has invested half
a billion dollars in Magic Leap,
which got $1.4 billion without
having a customer or a product.
So that proves you don't need
to have adoption to get funded.
[LAUGH] But you do have to have a bad
ass CEO who can convince people to
put that kind of investment in.
Anyways, our world is about to change.
This is where I'm going with this.
And [COUGH] when you do get mixed reality,
you get virtual reality and
augmented reality at the same time.
This is a little video that's
done through the Hololens and
he's showing you how he could
have a virtual door right here.
And you can walk through that door and
now you're in a virtual space and
I can't see you, right?
I'm just in a virtual space.
This is one advantage of these systems.
because they are going to
know every surface in here.
In fact, there was a company from Israel
that visited me a month ago called Yowza.
And it takes 3D images of this space.
And converts everything that's on
the table into a separate object.
So the Macintosh is up there,
it knows it's a separate
object from the table its on.
And then it starts doing
AI lookup on those objects.
So as I walk around, it's starting to see
logos and other features along the sides.
And it's trying to figure out
what kind of computer that is.
I used a system from Eyefluence
that Google just bought.
Eyefluence is an eye sensor company.
In fact, I think I have
a little [INAUDIBLE] of that.
Sorry, you're getting 45 minutes
of video in a few seconds.
There we go.
Do you have sound in this room?
If not,
I'll make it up because he's talking.
So Eyefluence, these glasses are soon
going to have eye sensors in them that
are going to watch your eyes move around.
And then we're going to see new kinds of
operating systems that are going to be
developed.
In fact, that's why I invited Meron
to come and talk with us because he's
building an operating system for these
glasses and he's also a neuroscientist.
>> So yeah, there you go.
>> Yeah.
So that's one reason I
invited Meron along.
And we're going to talk about operating
systems for these glasses and where you
think the brain Machine interface, they
came in machine interfaces about to go,
because he's one of the first people
who showed me gestures on hands.
His glasses see your hands and
let us do things with our fingers, and
soon with our eyes and with our voice.
So we're going to control
these devices in new ways.
And let's just watch a little bit.
This is Jim Marggraff who started
Eyefluence, just got sold to Google.
Watch the screen over on the left,
as he uses his eyes to control.
>> Small electronics in our office,
and I could go home when I want to.
Over here it's a medical application and-
>> All with your eyes.
>> All with my eyes.
So, I'm doing this solely with
my eyes as fast as I can look.
I'm not waiting, I'm not blinking,
I'm just looking.
And here I've got the patient.
I've got some allergy record,
protocols, insurance,
confidential information,
current conditions.
Why is he here?
Well he tells me he's
got a pain in his foot.
Notice I'm looking at this, but
there's nothing happening on the screen.
But when I decide, for instance, that I
want to check out His X-ray, there it is.
And now I want to go back,
because a couple screens ago,
there was some confidential information,
which is here.
And now,
it's going to take a picture of my eye.
It grabs it, says, ' who is that?'
confirms that it's me, and in a moment,
you'll see that it will give me
access on Jim, head of and CEO,
Founder of Eyefluence.
And there it is,
I've got confidential information.
When I want to I can return
home as fast as that.
>> That's amazing.
>> All with my eyes.
>> Now I filmed this at South
by Southwest last year.
So almost a year ago.
And he showed me a new glass that he's
working on and a new operating system.
And he said pull something
out of your pocket.
I pulled out my iPhone,
put it on the table.
He said look at it.
And a menu popped off the iPhone and
let me see what.
First of all it recognised it accurately.
It was an iPhone 6 S plus.
And then a menu popped up and
said would you like information on it or
would you like to buy it.
The price is 699 dollars
on Amazon all with my eyes.
So think about blocking around
using my eyes to control
display surface is in many as
in all sorts of fun stuff.
We could talk about this stuff for hours-
>> [LAUGH]
>> And not touch much of it, right?
So I'm really out of here.
We're going to bring up Mayron who
is building the operating system for
these glasses.
And then I'm going to
bring up Allspace VR.
>> Eric.
>> Jim Romho who is
building this as a social space.
So, we're going to hear it from two
different point of view in this new and
up and coming industry.
Two different people, one is building
a social experience that you can go and
dance in or I give a book reading
like this in AltspaceVR and
you can do a lot of
different things there.
Meta is building glasses that
are similar to HoloLens, has a sensor
to sense the room, has optics that put
virtual things on top of the real world.
And soon we'll have other things,
I'll let them talk.
I'm going to introduce them and then
we'll come back and get deeper into it.
So, thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I
think we want to start with Eric,
is that good?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> Yeah, yeah,
yeah sounds good, sounds good.
>> I don't have any slides-
>> That's fine, just leave that one.
>> I'll just talk to Robert's slides,
maybe.
>> Actually,
I do have AltspaceVR on one of my slides.
>> You got one?
Okay perfect, perfect.
So my name is Eric Romo.
I'm the founder and CEO of AltspaceVR.
It's great to be here actually because I
was in your seats about a dozen years ago.
So I'm a GSB 06.
I guess not literally in your seats,
because this was a parking
lot at that point.
But in a much less nice building
than this, a dozen years ago.
So I left business school, I started
a solar technology company called
GreenVolts, I helped run that for
about six and a half years.
And then made the very obvious transition
from solar technology to virtual reality.
Now I got bit by the bug
in VR probably about 2010.
And then in 2011, I read a book
by a guy named Jeremy Bilnson,
who I gather you just met.
Jeremy runs the virtual human interaction
lab here, the VR lab at Stanford.
And this got me really thinking
about human connection in VR, and
how we connect and how we interact.
With people.
I'll get to that in a second.
One thing I wanted to mention that's
slightly off that topic is I think it's
really exciting that you guys
have this concept of this class,
designing for your VR, because there's
a lot going on in the hardware and
the technology and the software.
It's really confusing.
It's confusing to us in this space.
So many different things in headsets and
operating systems.
My advice to you in thinking
about this class is get past that
as fast as possible, because what you
want to get to is you want to get to,
what really connects people?
What really moves people
about these technologies?
Engineers like me,
I'm a mechanical engineer, my background.
I worked at Space X
before business school.
We get really caught up
in all the numbers and
details, pixel density,
display resolution, and all this stuff.
What really matters,
is what's going to move people.
What is it that's going to get you to your
core, that will move you emotionally.
Why are you going to use these
technologies, why do you care?
And, I think, designing NBR,
designing an AR, get's the heart of that.
Why do we want to do things.
So, some folks have mentioned what
people call a social VR company.
This is where we're lumped into that space
with a few other folks including our
friends in Menlow park.
And we really think that's
kind of a misnomer,
the way we think about virtual
reality as a medium for communication.
So we think of ourselves as
a communications company.
The same way you think about
the video chat or audio chat or
text messages as being a methodology
of electronic communications,
medium of electronic indication.
We think that VR as something that's
going to enable a new kind of connection.
So much so that we have a thesis that if
VR is going to be successful commercially,
it will be because people are connecting.
If it's going to be something
that's well beyond Gamers and
some entertainment,
it's because people are feeling
an emotional connection that
wasn't available for them before.
So the question that we ask
ourselves is what do we get from VR?
What are the things about VR
that makes it a new medium.
[NOISE] And
when I started researching this space.
It started with the neuroscience
of connection, and
how our brains would use VR and reading
things like professor Valenson works on.
And VR if nothing else,
is really a tool for
fooling your brain into
thinking you're someplace else.
And so if we can fool you to
think your someplace else,
we can fool you to think you're
there with other people.
And so then the question is, what is it
that we get from being actually physically
present with other people that we don't
get in electronic communications media?
What is it that's different about this
experience of sitting in a room together
then watching this on YouTube watchroom?
How different is the experience that
your having then that they're having?
And you could argue that well they
see the same guy in the blue sweater
saying the same words at the same time.
Actually 30 or
45 seconds later probably, right?
So you could argue that the information
conveyed is largely similar.
But I think you would never make
the argument that sitting in the audience
at a Ted Talk is the same as
watching a TED Talk on YouTube.
That sitting in the audience
at a comedy show is the same
as watching a comedy special on Netflix.
That being at a concert is the same
as listening to a CD of a concert.
Are that, being in the same room
with your family is the same as
being on video chat with your family,
I think you'd never make that.
So when you think about that problem and
say, decompose.
What is it that we get when we're
physically together that we don't
have on these electronic media.
Well, it's things like this.
I can chose which one of you
I'm interacting with and
what [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sorry.
>> That's okay.
[LAUGH] How we feel when we interact,
when we make eye contact,
is dramatically different than
how we can feel on video chat.
Our ability to change the distance of
how far we are from each other connotes
something, hi.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right?
We feel that sense of physical space
that we don't have on video chat.
I have the ability to draw your
attention to something and
to know if you're looking at it.
So this is all what we talk about
as non-verbal communication.
You're all intimately aware of the people
who are to your left and right,
even if don't interact with them.
Even if you're not talking to them,
you're not looking at them,
you know there's somebody there.
And the feeling of being in this crowd,
that emotion that comes from that,
the connection that comes from
that is something that you don't
have in electronic communications media,
but you do have in virtual reality.
So the first thing that we really get
when we're together that we also get in
virtual reality that we
don't have in video chat,
that we don't have in phone calls
is non-verbal communication.
This way to communicate we call more
naturally than you can communicate
otherwise online.
Okay, the second big thing you get in
VR that you don't have in video chat or
audio chat is what we call
the context of communication.
What can we do together?
You think about video chat, you pretty
much just stare at each other and talk.
Actually, you stare kind of at each other.
Mostly you look at your picture in
the bottom right hand corner, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Through a phone call,
all you can do is talk, okay?
You can maybe find a counter-example
in video games or something.
You can talk while you play a video game.
But most of the time,
when we get together socially,
we get together from a professional
setting, there's something we're doing
together that forms a centerpiece
of that communication.
So you think about when you
get together with friends.
You play a card game, you cook,
you throw a Frisbee, you go for a walk,
you watch a movie.
Think about when you get there,
in a business setting,
you're going to have a white board,
you're going to have slides,
some kind of presentation.
You have documents you're reviewing.
There's some media, there's something
that forms the centerpiece of most of our
communications experiences.
And most of the time, electronically,
that's really terrible.
You're in there trying to do
a whiteboarding session on Skype or
on Google Hangouts.
It's a miserable experience.
And this is why we fly, as I once did,
18 hours each way to Santiago, Chile, for
a 90-minute meeting.
It absurd, it's absurd.
If you think about, really think about
why we travel all this distance,
it's for simple things like that.
For non-verbal communication and for the
ability to have context in communication.
So in VR we see as this medium where
we start to get this stuff back.
And that's really exciting.
So we think about what this is
going to be, that's what we focus on.
Now I gather you all visited
the Virtual Human Interaction Lab today,
which is awesome, the VR Lab at Stanford.
We only started calling it the VR Lab
a few years ago when VR got cool.
It used to be the VHIL.
One of the things I'll
touch upon because it's so
core to this concept of connecting,
and I know you were just there,
is how people think about
communicating in virtual spaces.
because I put on this headset, right?
And I look around this room,
and I see other people.
But I don't see photorealistic
representations of people, I see avatars.
And that consciously, for
most people, when they hear that,
when they see pictures of that, they might
see videos of that, they think, gosh,
I'm not going to like that.
I don't think I personally,
[SOUND] you can stand up on stage and
tell me you're going to
feel emotionally connected.
But I don't think I personally am going to
be emotionally connected by that.
It's a really fascinating piece
of research that they've done.
They've done tons of
studies on this stuff.
And the way I would summarize it for
you, and
you can suspend your disbelief until
you have experiences around this.
Is that we consciously expect that we're
not going to enjoy these experiences and
not be connected with
these people as avatars.
But subconsciously,
when you measure what happens,
when you actually get into the experience,
and you see people's responses.
And you objectively measure it,
rather than subjectively measure it.
They are connected, and in fact they can
be more connected than when I talk on
video chat and
I kind of can't make eye contact with you.
And so even when those avatars
are tremendously abstract,
as you'll see spheres with two dots for
eyes, okay?
And if that sphere with two dots for
eyes gets really close to you,
you're going to feel like
there's a person there.
So since you were there,
I wanted to touch upon that, but-
>> And not just people.
The reason I put this video up, this is me
playing in Chris Milk's latest creation,
Life With Us, at Sundance last week.
And I'm playing with them, and Greenberg,
who started Gracenote, next to me.
So we're both in this experience, and
Chris takes you on a journey
from an egg to adulthood.
And takes you through a number
of different characters.
So instantly, he throws you
off a cliff and you're flying.
And within a second,
I watched several people play it.
Within a second, everybody got,
wait a second, I have wings, I can fly?
I'm flying.
And you have empathy for
that character, and
you start behaving like that character.
You start running when
you're a dinosaur or an ape.
I think I'm an ape, right now,
with a monkey on my back.
[LAUGH] Which is sort of funny.
You can grab the monkey and
throw him off, right?
Grab the monkey off your friend, who's
playing with you, and throw them off.
But you're quickly get into that.
And the voices he is pushing
back at you are your own voices.
But changed to the character that
you're seeing on the screen in VR.
So it's quite fascinating.
And it show you the state of the art of
social behaviors in a VR setting, right?
>> This is one of this things.
I've been doing this for four years now.
And I have this experience over and over
again where I can talk until I'm blue in
the face about how you're going to feel
in situations like this or in social VR.
And people say, yeah, yeah, I get it.
And then 90 seconds into
actually having that experience,
how they feel is dramatically transformed.
So suspend your disbelief and
enjoy, thanks for having me.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yeah, yeah!
So Meron, God,
how do I explain how I met you?
The first time that I met him, he had 30
nerds up in this mansion up in Woodside.
With a tank collection in the backyard
which it was there from the guy who owned
the mansion back then.
And-
>> Actually,
the largest private collection
of military tanks in the world.
>> Yeah, not any more because
the family sold them all off.
But his team was building
software to study gestures.
And it took me back to my time at
Microsoft when I got a tour of
Microsoft Research.
I worked there for three years.
And Andy Wilson had a lab there and
was showing me how his algorithms
would see your fingers closing.
And would give you a control surface
on those fingers, gestures, right?
And you could do things with your hands
to zoom in on maps and stuff like that.
And you guys took that to a whole
new level and impressed me a lot.
And you're still on this mission
because your mission is to bring us
these glasses that'll do wondrous things.
So take it away, and I'll turn this off,
otherwise it'll be very distractive for
you.
>> [CROSSTALK] and thanks for
having me everyone.
So [COUGH] I'm want to tell you
a little bit about my company.
About why we're building
an operating system for
the mind, for augmented reality.
What that kind of an operating
system might look like.
And what's our focus,
as it compares to everyone else here.
You're hearing a lot about augmented and
virtual reality, I'm sure.
So let's try and
make sense of all of this.
So we build augmented reality
glasses that are very immersive.
They allow you to see pretty much
photorealistic imagery in space.
And you have this large
screen to be able to see it.
But you also see the real
world in the background.
And you can touch these
holograms with your very hands.
You can interact collaboratively and
that kind of thing.
So that's the basics of what Meta does,
very similar to
the Microsoft HoloLens in some ways.
However, unlike other people out there,
we're really
kind of obsessed with building
the most optimal operating system.
That really feels like
an extension of your imagination.
Because the power in our minds,
of holograms,
is to be able to simplify computing.
In essence we believe that your Iron Man,
Tony Stark workspace can allow you to
create a much easier computing experience.
If I'm surrounded by 3D models
that work the way my brain does.
In 3D and I can collaborate with you and
we can pass each other files back and
forth.
And I might have some supplementary
panel information that we can discuss.
And I might have a 3D Skype person
kind of holographically telepresence
into the room and have a natural
discussion the way we are here.
And computing can be
simplified dramatically.
So, that's our mission statement,
is really to drive towards
a zero learning curve,
computing experience, whatever that is.
My grandmother,
we bought her an iPad, and,
of course, this was the first time she was
able to adopt computers, or computing.
And what's the killer app for old people?
>> Facebook.
>> Solitaire
>> Facebook, correct, close.
Solitaire was on Windows 95,
but you couldn't get that and
that's the whole basis for
my speech today.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Words With Friends.
>> Words With Friends,
getting there, warming up.
>> Scrabble.
>> Scrabble, even simpler.
Looking at pictures of her grandkids.
So, pinch to zoom, that was
the killer app for my grandma, right?
There's a zero learning curve computer
experience that you just don't have
in windows 95 before.
So she was able to adopt computing for
the very first time.
But when we told her grandma, change
the brightness on your iPad, no way.
You have to go through a series of
complex menus and buttons and icons,
abstractions, to get to that point
where you're changing the brightness.
She couldn't figure it out.
So there's a lot of learning curves still
inside the easiest to use operating system
in the world, iOS.
And what we think we can do with AR is
eradicate that learning curve completely
and make something that
really is as natural and
as simple as that pinch to
zoom across the whole OS.
And a set of applications to do that.
The reason I put this girl behind here.
This four year old came into, this is my
house, and she came into my house and
immediately picked up the headset and the
controllers without talking to anybody.
She'd never been in it before.
And with it zero instructions,
she just went to town.
And I talked to you about this say,
this is your goal to make
every experience in computing
this easy for people to pick up.
We are going to be talking about this
very application in just a moment,
tilt brush which I hope you've all
tried because it's freaking awesome.
And it allows you to draw holographically
in space, in virtual reality.
Now this ability of a 2 year old child or
an 80 year old grandfather to just
pick up the tool and start drawing, start
working is something that is completely
distinguishable from any
computing paradigm before.
>From anything you can do on a Windows or
even an iOS device.
So, we're going to get
to it in just a moment.
So, that's what we build, builds augmented
reality holographic tools that allow any
thinker or builder or creator to visualize
their imagination and their work in space.
So, everyone in this room would be
able to use our headset for something.
And we can get into the specifics for
that in just a moment.
So Jennifer asked me to focus
on how we create an open culture
that is empathetic to the market and
to our employees and our partners.
So I have two examples of this.
The first is,
us opening our offices this quarter.
So we are about 150
people now at San Mateo.
We took over GoPro's old office space.
And for those of you who might have
seen my TED talk from last year,
we promised a pretty bombastic promise.
And that was that we were going to
by TED of 2017 throw away all of our
external monitors,
essentially throw away our monitors.
Our beloved multi-screen
station into the garbage and
replacing it with an AR experience.
So, why did we do this?
We did this because there's a sensation
in the market that there's,
that AR and VR, specially AR,
are vapor wear, that it's not real,
that it's far away from being useful.
And by us embodying and
really trying out these use cases and
being the first AR enabled office space in
the world, we were hoping to dispel that.
Now you might have heard of some
woes that a competitor of ours has
gotten into in the last few months,
because of over hyping technology and
not being there when it
comes to the actual product.
So we're hoping to undo that, and
bring in people into our company.
So this openness is very literal,
we're inviting anyone,
any academic, any journalist,
anyone to come over to our offices and
experience what it might look like
to be inside of augmented reality
exclusively without
a traditional computer.
And that should be a really
exciting quarter for
us, as we throw away all of our monitors.
And that means everyone,
the engineer, my assistant, everyone.
So that's the first way,
the second way is,
remember we're focused in
on this operating system.
This holy grail of computing
that will simplify things for
grandmothers across the land.
Now we believe the pathway to that
is by understanding how grandma and
grandpa process information.
In other words, neuroscience.
So by understanding cognitive neuroscience
is fairly in-depth, and creating
a set of simple design guidelines,
we believe we can create that experience.
The Tilt Brush experience and create
an infinite number of applications that
feel as simple as that
computing experience.
So I'd like to tell you about
a couple of those principles.
But before I do, I'll just say that we're
open sourcing our design guidelines for
designing this OS.
And that's another way we're trying
to open up to the community and
you might ask,
why on earth would you do that?
And, if you're focused in such
a crowded complex ecosystem is on
the operating system, why would you
tell your competitors how to build it.
The answer is, like in virtual reality,
if one person gets a negative
experience it tends to reflect
on the rest of the industry.
So my hope is that our competitors will
look into these design guidelines and
will try and
make more delightful computing experiences
that will uplift the whole industry.
So that's the design guideline.
Let's talk about just two of them and
then we'll wrap up and pass the mic back.
So Tilt Brush, so so cool, right.
And our competitor comes from originally,
Oculus had a demo and now Vibe.
>> It's made by Google, yeah.
>> It was made by Skillman and
Hackett that were bought by Google.
And look at the transmitting
of imagination into creation.
In a sense,
there's no latency between the two,
we've increased the I/O between man and
machine with this kind of an application.
And I think that with a set of about
ten simple easy to understand design
guidelines, anyone can build a Tilt Brush.
And tiltbrush is considered in
many circles the killer app of VR,
its a driving adoption in many
senses of virtual reality.
Even more than the games that people
thought would drive adoption.
So two little stories on
how to build a tiltbrush.
The first is our principle which
is called minimize abstractions.
So, minimize abstractions has to do with
our philosophy around spatial computing.
Spatial graphical user interface, we
believe is the next 50 years of computing.
It's going to engulf every AR and
VR company that is trying to build
an operating system will adopt
roughly the spatial computing.
So, let's go ahead and define it.
Before we do, let's define what it's
changing, what it's disrupting.
This is the Windows
graphical user interface,
sort of summarized by the acronym WIMP,
Windows, Icons,
Menus and Pointers,
created in Xerox PARC in '72.
And then Steve Jobs pulled it
into Apple for the Mac and
then Gates took it into Windows 95,
iOS took it back.
Fundamentally all of these operating
systems are about a metaphorical window
being able to close it being able to see
your home screen, iconography, menus.
That's what the last 50
years of computing is.
That's where your imaginations have been
trapped in the last 50 years of computing.
And what we're hoping is
that the next 50 years,
we'll free them like that
tiltbrush experience.
And here's a particular
way that we can do this.
The first principle we
call minimize obstruction.
So if in the old world that was
about menus and windows and
all this complexity, the new world is
about two things and two things alone.
Tools and content.
That's it, that's all the animals
that matter in the new world.
So let's imagine Photoshop of the past,
right?
Photoshop of the past,
it's riddled with all this abstraction,
different layering systems, side panels,
crowding on top of each other.
How long does it take me to get to
the damn paint brush and customize it?
By the time I got there I got burnt out, I
don't have a creation, I can't do that for
sure as a novice in Photoshop.
That's the old world, but
what's the new world look like
when it comes just to tools and
content and AR or VR?
Well, it's as simple as seeing that
paintbrush, picking it up, and
maybe putting on a different header to it,
dipping it in some paint,
and starting with the paint.
And that process is where computing
is going, into tools and content.
Those are the two buckets.
So, how do we design these tools?
We're talking about designing for AR VR.
I'll wrap up in just about a minute.
We design them with affordances.
We take cues from
the industrial design world.
Affordances are these things
like a handle for a teacup or
the little nooks on the side of a hammer
where it tells me how to grab it.
These things essentially tell
the brain how to grab it.
Now, Professor in 2001,
discovered, and all of our guidelines
are anchored on neuroscience.
He discovered that there's this area
called R4, sorry, F4, in the motor cortex.
Which is controlling
the movement of the hand.
That looks at objects,
at the characteristics of objects, and
reverse engineers those
characteristics to create an automatic
series of motor commands to allow you
to reach out and grab the object.
So the object is telling
you how to use it.
That's what we're talking about.
That's how you eradicate
the learning curve from computing.
So that's one way in which we're going to
create a bunch of tiltbrushes, together.
The other way is what we called augmented,
not mixed, reality.
Robert likes this term mixed reality and
I don't, so
today we'll have a little bit of a debate.
So Professor asked me
to imagine the future with you guys,
and conclude this talk.
So I want you to imagine yourself in
about five years waking up in bed.
And rolling over and reaching for
that familiar thing.
Hopefully for our shareholders that's not
an iPhone, that's a pair of AR glasses.
And how do these glasses look?
They look like a strip of
glass that's nearly invisible.
>From the distance that we're standing from
each other they're even less of a visual
footprint than my glasses.
You put the strip of glass on and you can
see photorealistic light field holograms.
My friends, we're working on these
kinds of glasses, magically, Microsoft,
everyone is, and this hardware I
promise you will soon be commoditized.
So when yo talk about getting
away from talking about specs and
obsessing on the pixel size,
that's wise because
what the important thing is what
you put inside of these glasses.
Every little nuance and
difference is going to change the lives
of everyone adopting this afterwards.
I was just sitting with Scott Forstall
in my office a couple of days ago.
Scott was the designer of iOS.
He essentially is responsible for
a lot of the iPhone.
And he's looking around in SFO at
an army of people just hunching over and
he says it's really upsetting what world
we've brought forward, what we've created.
>> Hey, at least we're not
locked to our desks anymore.
[LAUGH].
>> Fair enough.
I told him I think we've turned into
a species of phone monkeys, but
that's just my theory.
So, I said, yes, we gotta fix this,
and this is how we can fix it.
We have a few different ways.
So you put on the strip of glass,
back into that morning.
And, the first thing you see is
an explosion on the side of your wall,
just like you saw in
this hollow lens thing.
And a dinosaur comes rushing in and
this dinosaur is photo realistic and that
hole looks is real as can be and it sure
as hell wakes you up better than a coffee.
And this dinosaur's running through
the room with a notification in its mouth,
did you forget milk this morning?
Notification from your wife.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Given through the dinosaur.
I don't know, I'm just making this UI up.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So this is option A.
It's called mixed reality.
Mixed reality means to warp a part
of your reality like a wall and
blast the hole through it and
change it to warp it.
Let's imagine a different reality.
You put on your headset, nothing happens
until you want it to, you get up.
You go to Crystal Lake, you take a little
bit of a jog by the side of the lake and
on the side you see a flower
that kind of attracts you.
It's interesting and you touch it,
and right next to it comes a meta user
interface, a meta UI like metadata,
that's how I'm using the word meta now.
That just tells you,
it's a Wiki panel that tells you how
much DNA you share with the flower.
So, it enriches, it deepens
the relationship between you and
the world, okay?
And then you keep jogging,
keep going on your jogging.
You see someone at a distance and
that person is from this class,
from Jennifer's class.
And you didn't know that because
the jogger's at a distance.
And in turns out that you could
see with a panel right next
to them that they can also see, so
it's not creepy like Google Glass that
they are also Grateful Dead fans like you.
So by the time they arrive, by the time
you cross paths, you can reach out,
shake their hand, become friends on
Facebook perhaps, and continue the run.
This is another example of a meta
UI that deepens your connection
With the real world and with each other,
people in the real world.
So I want to create that world.
A world were it's not distorted,
it's not manipulated but
it's rather augmented and
that's why I love this term augmented.
So that's our last principle
called augmented not mixed.
There's a lot of neuroscience to suggest
why it's better to not have dinosaurs
breaking through walls, and
that change all of your, what we call,
Bayesian priors of your brain,
your mental model of your brain.
All the time can change if
there's no laws of physics.
And that can create sort
of delusional thinking or
anxiety around what's
going to happen next.
So there's a lot of neuroscience behind
all these things but I just wanted
to give you a taste of what we think
about everyday and why is this important?
Well, because the next 50 years of
computing are going to be anchored on
the next iOS.
And our kids are going to grow up inside
of these things and our kids kids so
we want to make sure they
have a comfortable stay.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Awesome, come on up.
Yeah, that was awesome.
>> Thank you.
>> How do I add more
value to you right now?
You're getting a taste in this class,
over the next few months, you are going to
probably hear from some of the people that
built some of the stuff I've showed you.
I just came back from Sundance and
I saw films from as crazy
an experience that started out
with looking at a gay sex act and
VR to Chris Mill's thing where
you're flying through space with
another person is quite amazing.
How do you think these
systems will philosophically
differ from each other because that I
sense that you have a deeper philosophical
difference from some of the other
people who are building these systems.
Because let's to go dystopian,
there's a Japan,
in fact I should pull up the Japanese
video where he puts ads on every,
this Japanese filmmaker made a video where
he pretends we're in this new world,
and he puts ads and other information
on every surface around him.
And sounds like you don't
like that kind of future.
>> [LAUGH] I hope we don't all like
that or we all don't like that future.
But yes, that's the future we're
trying to protect against.
So there will be philosophical differences
that are inherent in the form factor.
Virtual reality seeks to pull you into
another world, maybe deepen the connection
with other people inside of that world,
in this mediation phase.
But mixed reality seeks to stimulate
you by changing the characteristics
of the world and augmented is simply a way
to enrich your life with more information
about the real world, real people in the
real world and objects in the real world.
I'm excited about that and I think when we
think about the far future it's going to
go inside of glasses and then who knows,
brain computer interfaces in the future,
who knows where it's going to go.
But as we become more intimately connected
with the machine we want to make sure that
it's a great experience.
Because it's so
easy to manipulate someones thoughts.
And we show the neuroscience of how
easy it is to generate delusions in
a healthy person's mind, that we think
we have a bit of a responsibility.
>> We should talk about these downsides.
In my book we have a whole
chapter on possible downsides,
control of people,
delusions, and other things.
We should talk about that.
The upside is this is a drug.
I've been telling my friends
this is LSD for everybody.
>> [LAUGH]
>> because if I want that wall to be
a multicolored array of ants,
I can make it happen.
In fact, I'm starting to write a list
of rules of this new mixed reality
role world and
the first rule is there's nothing you can
tell me about this world that is false.
[LAUGH] Visually at least.
>> Right, right.
>> I thought it was going to be no
multicolored hands, the first rule.
>> No multicolored, no, whatever you want
to put on that wall, you can make it.
>> The key is, Robert, it's fine for
you to pull the multicolored answer but
you the user have to be in control and
this is the nuance.
Thus far the developer's the god and
what we're trying to make sure of as the
developer gets a monopoly over your whole
field of view is that you become
the controller of your own destiny.
I want to put the ants on,
that's my UI, that's my app.
But don't have that
automatically be part of the OS.
Big no-no, I think.
>> Yeah, it's a slippery slope though.
I mean, you look at the majority
of the revenue from the major
tech companies in the valley, now the new
breed, Google, Facebook is advertising.
And so if these are going to be the
companies that are the vanguard of these
new technologies, whether they be
AR of VR or MR or whatever that is.
How are they not going to
cater towards that?
It's where 97 plus percent
of their revenue comes from.
So when they say, it's very reasonable for
me to put a little ad there and
then charge you less for
your head set that's a step down the road.
And then when they say
it's very reasonable for
me to have you watch an ad before
you put on your headsets so
it's a little cheaper,
that's another step down the road.
So I think it's going to be a big
challenge because so much of the economy
of Internet companies, the tech companies,
is built upon advertising.
And so much of those companies
are the ones who are spending
hundreds of millions and billions of
dollars on developing these technologies.
>> That should really alarm us.
>> It should but it doesn't, right?
We deal with that at Facebook,
we deal with that at Twitter,
we deal with that in social
media we use every single day.
>> Here I visited Sephora's R&D lab and
they showed me an augmented makeup
Where [COUGH] with your iPhone today,
you can aim your iPhone at your face and
try on different kinds of makeup,
lipsticks and what not.
And the color is matched
to the physical product.
So when you got to Sephora and
actually buy the real makeup it's
matched to what you see on the screen.
And imagine I have these glasses on,
now you could be a KISS character or
some weird made-up character, right.
It's going to be crazy in this new world.
I don't know that your philosophy
is going to completely win.
because we're going to try a lot of things
and some of them are going to work.
>> To be honest, it's not a philosophy and
this is what we're trying to
really document in this guideline.
We're just trying to find out how
the brain likes to process information.
And if the brain, and
there's many examples of this, but
if the brain wants to put augmented
costume and makeup on you right now for
whatever task then that's what
it should be allowed to do.
The problem is when the brain,
when a developer decides that, and then I,
a simple user of MR,
will not know if that is real or not real.
And then it becomes a slippery slope to,
am I talking to scobo here or
am I talking to an AI?
Am I talking to some kind of an avatar
that's completely sort of realistic here?
Should I shake your hand or
will it just go through air?
These kinds of confusions,
they're just simply mental confusions.
And we want to make sure that we have
a guideline that allows for that beautiful
crazy future, but makes sure that
we're protected as we go in there.
That's our goal.
>> Talked about protection,
I'm sexual abuse victim so
I care about this topic very deeply.
When we are in virtual social spaces there
will be bad actors in that social space.
How do you protect people from that
kind of activity in one of these spaces?
And both of you, take that on.
>> Yeah, it's a huge challenge because
if the whole point of your product is to
make you feel like you're there with other
people you have to choose what
people you're there with.
The early days of virtual reality and
to set context, there's probably
Somewhere between 1 and 2 million people
a month that use virtual reality headsets,
in the brackets that matter, not in the
Google Glass, Google Cardboard, excuse me,
frame of things.
Those are sort of irrelevant.
If I use them for
30 seconds that's a long session.
We are talking about Samsung's Gear VR,
and Oculus Rift, and HTC Vive,
and Google Daydream.
If the whole point of those products is
to make you feel like you are with other
people, if you are with
the wrong people that can be
an extremely negative experience.
You do have this concept
of personal space.
And you do have this concept where people
have hands and when those hands come
towards you, you feel like someone's
hand is coming towards you.
You have the same visceral emotional
reaction like this, which is a good one.
This is a good one.
But if it's a stranger,
that's not necessarily a good feeling.
And so where we are is in this challenging
place where we, I can just say for
us as a company, is the social
bureaucratic people use a lot is.
Is that we're trying to learn what
makes a good user interaction
in a world where most users don't actually
know anybody else that has a VR headset.
I mean the probability that
your friend has a VR headset so
you can hang out in our product or any
other one is diminishing small right now.
So by definition you have groups of
people who don't know each other and
so you have this possibility for
interaction.
Now what happens is again,
we try to, you're mirroring sort
of what happens in real life.
But the problem is in real life you got
a police force, and you got somebody's
cousin is going to punch you in
the nose if you do something wrong.
They don't necessarily have that in VR.
So you don't have this same
social rules that you have there.
So you need to design them in about
how you bring people together and
what tools you allow people to say,
okay yeah you,
you're out of here, and
just get rid of them instantly.
It's a challenging and
interesting problem, and
it's not unlike the problems that
Twitter has been totally unable to
address on their platform but
to a different
level because of the psychological
experience of that connection.
>> Is it true in your system,
it might be your system or somebody elses.
But if I try to touch you inappropriately,
my hand turns around toward me?
>> It just disappears the way we do it,
yeah.
So disappears for you, it disappears for
everyone else so no one can see it.
Some systems have designed to where,
I try to move my hand toward you and
you don't see it.
But everybody else in the room sees
me harassing you in some way which
doesn't solve the problem we think.
So the harder way to solve that was to
make sure it disappears for everybody.
It sounds like a simple design thing,
right, but
it's actually a very challenging
design and technical problem.
>> Designing this world of etiquette
in virtual reality is super,
super interesting.
In augmented reality,
there's a similar question because,
assume for a moment the term augmented
reality covers a lot of things,
including even Google Glass.
When we had Glass,
people were looking at each other and
they weren't really sure what
was happening on the other side.
There were these asymmetrical UIs that I
believe was the downfall of the product.
More than the look,
which was geeky, that's fine.
The form factor is less of a concern for
me.
It's the fact that I just don't know
what you're looking at right now.
I don't know if you're recording it but
me, right now, by design,
they actually designed it that way.
So, one of our principles,
and the brain has so
much processing around attentional cues.
Like, if you're looking at me right now, I
have this area in my medial temporal lobe
called a fusiform gyrus which
is analyzing the whites-
>> Wait, slow down what did you just say?
>> I have this area that is analyzing your
facial features to know if you're paying
attention to me.
To know if you're aroused by
whatever I'm saying right now, etc.
And when you use your hands there's
this freaky cool thing which is that
the same area in your brain,
if you were to move your hands like this,
are now firing by you looking
at me moving my hands.
So we're matched.
There's this social
underpinning of empathy.
So our principle bottom line for
etiquette inside of AR is that everything
has to be viewed by everyone else.
It's public by default,
this is one of our principles.
So, let's warm up,
I'm trying to spice it up guys.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Come on work with me here.
>> Because if it's
>> That sounds crazy.
I want privacy.
All right, let's talk about it.
>> If it is public and I believe that by
the end of the year, we're going to see
several companies bring out a new
kind of 3D map based on Slam, right?
Where the glasses are going to see this
world and are going to remember it.
Right, if I use my HoloLens,
I can put a shark here.
>> Yeah.
>> And if I come back a year from now,
that shark will be right where I left it.
>> Great.
>> And if I could publicly share
that shark with the class,
the whole class would see the shark here,
right?
>> Uh-huh, and that's exactly what we
actually we promote, in this new world.
We want the world to
feel like an architecture
office where you come to visit.
You see all these beautiful creations.
You can share them with one another.
And if you want to chuck one,
you just pick it up and throw it away and
it's gone.
I think if you imagine yourself here
in a couple of years in this classroom,
all of us wearing our headsets.
Just the beautiful colors and
mise-en-scène around us is
such a cool visual to have.
And for some of that to be private or
hidden from one another just because it's
my creation and not yours, it deviates so
much from our mental model of the real
world that it's not worth it.
>> But in my glasses I'm watching stuff
that I might not want you to see.
>> So
do what you're doing in the real world.
Go to the other room and do it there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's my point though.
It's the nuance,
it's that etiquette prevails.
The social norms that we're talking
about that sort of get in to VR and
control the way we design our UIs will be
the same, I think, for augmented reality.
But I don't know if you guys have seen
the Blackmere episode with John Ham where
there's an offender and
one person looking at that offender only
sees their silhouette and the offender can
never talk, or never communicate back.
It's called diminished reality.
This is the opposite of all
that we're talking about.
And that's the world that, I think, a few
of the competitors are steering towards.
This is my private thing, I'm going to
create a silhouette around it but
here's the problem with that.
When I'm talking to a silhouette,
when I'm interacting with a silhouette
that you can't see, that confuses you.
And just creates a lot anxiety and
Google Glass feeling, I think,
in the room and we want to avoid that.
So, that's one of our little thingys.
>> At Coachella, big music festival,
Doppler Labs sold me
augmented hearing headphones.
And these headphones block the analog
audio from getting to your ear.
They have microphones on them.
They have processing,
and they have speaker.
In fact I have,
I can't show you what I have in my pocket.
But I have some headphones that
have six microphones on them.
And they're using artificial
intelligence to find my voice and
make it better, all sorts of fun stuff.
These Doppler labs,
they make the audio better.
They're doing to audio
what you're doing to-
>> To the world.
>> To visuals right?
And when you put them in,
keep in mind you're at Coachella and
you're in front of $2 million
worth of audio gear, so
you're having about as good an audio
experience as you're ever going to have.
Right, cus it's pretty bad ass.
But you put these stupid
$200 headphones in and
all of a sudden that sounds
better because it's augmented.
You can turn down the volume,
you can turn up the bass,
you can do all sorts of weird effects.
The noise cancelling on these new
products is unbelievable, right?
On and on, but what's weird is you
take them out and it's sounds better.
>> You take them out and
the real world sounds better.
>> The real world sounds better.
And you put them back in it sounds better.
>> [LAUGH]
>> How can it sound better both ways?
>> It depends what you took at Coachella.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Burn, but I was sober with these.
[LAUGH]
>> He's sober, he's sober.
>> I don't drink anymore, and I was
not using other things at that point.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And there's a principle here.
That our human mind likes analog and
likes augmented.
It likes both.
And Neil Young's audio engineer took
me into his audio lab over here,
and he played Harvest Moon off
of the two-inch analog tape
in the studio where it was recorded.
And then he had a series of devices where
he could show me the digital music,
all the way down to 44.1 kilohertz sampled
music which is what's on a CD or MP3 file.
You could really tell the difference
between that and analog.
Anybody who has a vinyl record
collection knows that analog
sounds better when you have
everything set up perfectly.
But I don't listen to analog
because it's not convenient, right?
My Spotify on my phone has thousands
of songs on my phone, right?
>> Here's the thing about convenience.
When it gets too convenient,
I stop listening to music.
It's like I turn into
a phone monkey again and
I'm like I just lose track of all of
the plethora colossal CD collection.
And then I just want to go home and
listen.
I literally just bought Harvest from Neil
Young, not Harvest Moon, in record form.
And I bought a record player last week and
I feel totally hipster for
doing this, and odd actually,
because it's so much less convenient.
But then I find myself sitting there,
isolated in the room, and
just listening to it and hearing every
little nuance off of the record.
So yes, we love our analog and
I'm the CEO of an AR company so
it's a crazy world that we're going into.
>> Where I'm going is,
I believe we're going to take
the glasses off a lot to check in.
First of all, if you're a supermodel
sitting in front of me right now,
I'm going to check to make sure,
wait a second, [LAUGH] right?
>> Because you're going to be able to
portray yourself however you want.
I mean,
we see already augmented reality makeup.
That ain't going to stop, right?
>> Nope.
>> If I have a slam based
mattress-
>> It will make augmented,
the term augmented literally.
>> I could get rid of you, right?
I could erase you from my visual world,
right?
I could put SpongeBob in it, right?
If I wanted to, you could be SpongeBob.
So I'm constantly going to be checking
to make sure that the world is accurate,
right, and
I'm still going to enjoy that analog way.
We still are a long way from
duplicating the nature's beauty, right?
You go to Yosemite, you might want
to see that augmented at some
places to know the names of the mountains
and know the names of the flowers and
all the stuff you were talking about.
But we're still going to want to
take the glasses off and
enjoy the analog wave-
>> I guess I believe in a symbiotic
future where you don't have
to take off the glasses, but
they're not trying to fool you.
And that's the nuance,
that's all that I talk about.
If you design your UI in
a way that's natural and
that cares about the beauty of the world,
then you can win.
>> Let's go deep.
I have an app on my-
>> Do we still have time?
I got a two-minute signal across there.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Questions?
>> What?
>> Okay, sure.
>> It gets a little messy.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have an app on my HoloLens
called Fragments,
where a murder happens right in the room.
So
it maps out the room.
>> Yeah.
>> It finds every surface in the room and
puts a murder there.
And at one place, there's these artificial
rats that are running around the floor,
and because it knows the floor's surface,
it runs around your feet.
It knows where your feet are,
because the feet are different
than the floor surface, right?
And it's freaky, but it's quite enjoyable
to have that happen to you, right?
>> Sure.
>> So I'm not sure that humans
are going to resist this stuff the way you
hope-
>> I don't hope that they will.
I just hope that the designers of
the operating system of the future
won't make a rat or
colorful ant operating system.
But rather that will be left for the,
remember I said there were two animals in
the future, two UI components that
survive into the next generation?
Tools and content,
they become the content of the future.
Build your app, your entertainment-focused
app, around this crime scene and
let the democratic forces of the web
dictate how many downloads you have and
how successful you are and
how much VC money you get.
And let a lot of people enjoy that
experience by their own decision making.
And that's important.
>> And you'll get the last minute.
>> When I'm in AltspaceVR or some of the
other social VR spaces, there's going to
be infinite rooms or infinite places to
go and visit, whether it's a field and
there's a rave in the field, or a room
like this where I'm taking a class, or
an office where I have
multiple monitors around me.
>> How do I find those,
the coolest place in the future?
Because I find I struggle
to know where I should go.
>> Yeah.
>> because it's not like this where people
said, you gotta come into a room and
they direct me and we have lots of
structures to get people into place.
It's really hard in some
of these social views.
>> It's a fascinating challenge, because I
think most people's preconception of what
virtual reality will be is
a contiguous place, right?
They read all these Snow Crash and
Ready Player One, and these kind of bibles
of virtual reality universes and
they talk about planets and places you go.
We just think that's sort of
nonsense because the idea of this
continuity of a universe is impractical.
If I want to go to another place in VR,
I should just go there.
I don't have to pay somebody to walk
into a virtual telephone booth or
whatever the hell they
do in Ready Player One.
So we see it more as a model of,
it's the web,
where the places you go in
Altspace are literally websites.
You go to a URL and it downloads
all the stuff you need, and so
the discovery models will be
more like you have on the web.
You'll find it on social, you'll find
it on search, you'll find it that way.
So we see embracing how the web developed
in allowing our tools to help people
create these interesting places rather
than sort of enforcing that it must
somehow map to a real world.
>> Real fast, what's one or
two things that students should try
on a Vive or an Oculus or Gear VR?
>> Yeah, so I mean, I think-
>> Other than your own.
>> Other than our own.
I think Google Earth is so cool in VR.
It's on the Vibe, and
you can sort of find where you grew up and
walk around your hometown.
And it's just a really,
really great thing for sense of scale.
My favorite thing honestly
is sort of casual gaming,
which is totally anathema
to where VR started.
>> Superhot?
>> I haven't played Superhot yet,
but I love Fantastic Contraption,
which is just as cool.
If I was a kid and I had this I would
just go crazy, I'd be in there all day.
But there's that concept that VR is for
hardcore gamers because
that's where it came out of.
I just think that's not where it's
going to be where it is at all.
>> All the kids under 13
will have job simulators.
>> Job simulators, so cool.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's all stuff that, it's not,
I don't think there's been
a really successful, maybe one or
two really successful
more hardcore AAA games.
All the stuff that's really
compelling is just stuff that's
the VR equivalent of what
an iOS game would be.
It's just fun, addictive,
lighthearted, whimsical.
There's some great stuff out there.
>> Same question for you?
>> Tilt Brush, anatomy viewers,
I'm such a medical sciences geek that just
seeing them photorealistically in front
of me, being able to explode a body and
look really deep into, it is just always
going to make me feel like a kid.
It's awesome.
History, microbiology,
freaking looking up at the stars.
>> When you first put me
into augmented reality,
it made me cry because I realized how
much my life was about to change.
Why can I remember that feeling and
the imagery that you showed me?
>> It's so interesting that a lot
of people tell us I will never,
ever forget that first 3D
hologram that I looked at.
The brain remembers novelty.
It's a novelty machine.
It's never seen a photorealistic
object that has no matter,
that has no atoms, only photons,
and that is just jarring.
And so you'll always remember that.
And now it's up to the developers to
think about how they could use that fact.
What is the first image you want to
show a billion people in AR or
in VR, because that will never be erased?
>> Pokemon.
>> [LAUGH] That's one way to do it.
>> I think that's demo number
one on the new iPhone, come on.
Pokemon Hunter.
[LAUGH]
>> Man, yeah.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Pokemon, thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]